استهداف قاده في الحرس الثوري الايراني في
سوريا يمتد عده سنوات اذ قتل عدد من قاده
وافراد الحرس الثوري في سوريا جراء هجمات
اسرائيليه وفقا للحرس الثوري ففي يناير
2015 قتل العميد محمد علي علي الله دادي
جراء غاره جويه اسرائيليه على مزرعه الامل
في محافظه القنيطره جنوب غربي سوريا وفي
ابريل
2018 قتل سب افراد من الحرس الثوري في
هجوم اسرائيلي على مطار التيفور العسكري
في سوريا كما قتل في مارس
2022 العقدان احسان كربلائي وبور ومرتضى
سعيد انجاد خلال هجوم اسرائيلي على منطقه
قرب دمشق وفي مارس من العام الماضي قتل
مقداد مهجان جعفر ابادي
وميلاد حيدري من افرا راد الحرس الثوري
المعروفين بالمدافعين عن الحرم في غاره
اسرائيليه على محيط العاصمه
السوريا كما قتل المستشاران العسكريان
للحرس الثوري محمد علي عطاي شورجه وبناه
تقي زاد خلال هجوم اسرائيلي في سوريا في
ديسمبر الماضي كذلك في ديسمبر الماضي قتل
المستشار رضي موسوي جراء غاره اسرائيليه
صاروخيه في منقه السيده زينب في ريف دمشق
وكان موسوي برتبه لواء وهو مسؤول
وحده مسؤول وحده دعم يسميها الحرس الثوري
قوات المقاومه في
سوريا